en que la vida de muchos ciudadanos ha
dado un vuelco en busca de refugio de
las bombas rusas ahora muchos se adaptan
a la vida bajo tierra en las estaciones
de metro junto a sus familias
mis hijos se pusieron a llorar cuando su
padre se fue al frente
y les dije que estaríamos bien que su
padre regresaría por ellos pero son
capaces de entender que alguien puede
matarlo o dispararle aunque espero que
no lo hagan
según la onu durante el fin de semana
nacieron más de 81 bebés en búnkeres y
refugios en que entre ellos en las
estaciones de metro y es que algunas
paradas como la de toro hachís se han
convertido en pequeñas ciudades en sus
pasillos los niños corren y juegan
muchos permanecen casi a 70 metros
cargando el trauma de la guerra y no
quieren esa vida para sus hijos
espero que el ejército ruso que vino acá
para matarnos se marche para que
nuestros hijos no tengan que vivir así
en el metro sino que puedan pasear por
los parques con juguetes para que se
acabe este sufrimiento y las ancianas de
80 años no acaben su vida en el metro y
puedan envejecer felices
en
ciudades tan cercanas como hardcore o ir
pin pegada a la capital han sufrido
intensos bombardeos puntos desde los que
los civiles intentan huir amparándose en
los esperados corredores humanitarios